hello everybody my name is markiplier
and this is just going to be a short
video and video quality because I'm just
recording on a crappy camcorder that I
bought yesterday but I have some
important information for you the
charity livestream that I told you about
is coming up this Saturday February 22nd
this saturday starting at about 12 p.m.
Eastern Standard Time Bob wait and I
will all be in attendance so don't miss
it it's going to be so much fun we're
going to get in the room and do the same
thing that we always do which is just
have fun for you guys and raise money
for a great cause
child's play our goal this year or this
month rather is $80,000 and I know that
we can do that because we have done
almost as good in shorter planning time
than this and we've got so much time and
so many things planned it's going to be
so much fun and the t-shirt that I told
you about before the three separate
t-shirts one for me
Bob and Wade are on sale right now you
can buy them right now so you can get
them sooner hopefully not too soon after
the live screen actually ears if you
click the link in the description below
you'll find a link to the store they're
the three t-shirts available separately
and there is a bundle if you want to
save money and get all three they're
stickers they're patches all on sale
there is a link to a widget where you
can donate directly to the charity if
you just want to donate a few dollars or
you want to donate more and be awesome
it's PayPal you can takes credit cards
and the most important thing to remember
and when you're telling it is that all
all profit coming from these t-shirts
goes straight to the charity I don't
make a penny off of these t-shirt sales
I don't earn anything I don't want to
earn anything from these I want all the
money to go all the money possible to go
to charity and that is what we're doing
here so there's nothing shady at all
going on behind the scenes here so that
is the important information that I have
and we've done this before and it has
been so incredibly successful and I
can't wait to see how great this one is
going to be it's going to be amazing so
that's the important information that
once again I saw I apologize about the
echo and I've got something else to show
some of you if I
get this off the time something a little
close to you it's too much for you so
okay so now I've got this and you're
going to join me that's what this little
leave you the other apartments over
there you can't see my facebook okay
sorry I'm not used to do this I don't
usually have a camper okay so this is my
office it's what's going to be my office
and a lot of people have been requesting
this of me because there are a lot of
computer nerds like me out there that do
what I do and I build my own computer at
all times I've never bought my own
computer I don't know I can't get my
face in there okay I don't want to buy
my own computer I love the feel of
electronics and I love learning about
cool stuff like that all the time so
I've got a little treat because I build
myself a brand new computer when I came
out here to LA and it is done and it is
gorgeous there's a few more things than
I want but here take a look of it Shane
referring there we go okay so sorry it's
a bit dark but hopefully this will
automatically fix itself this is my baby
it is my new video editing and gaming
monster and actually let me get a light
in here boos won't look so bad
mmm Dada okay so now this is my new baby
the case is a slightly soundproof or at
least it's a quieter chassis it's a
mid-sized Tower not a full Tower because
I wanted it to be a bit more compact
than my last one because it was just too
bulky to move around the main part about
this is the motherboard is pretty good I
think it's like a what is it a saber
tooth x79 spice sous I don't really care
about the motherboard but the CPU is an
Intel 49 60 X Extreme Edition it's the
best consumer-level CPU that they have
and I got to set up the liquid cooling
right now for you computer enthusiastic
you'll probably know what I'm talking
about but I've got a setup right now is
a double exhaust out because that was a
specification this particular cooler but
ordinarily I would have it as an intake
fan but these up here are blocked off by
acoustic foam and hard plastic on the
top to reduce noise so I couldn't use
them as an intake without removing the
soundproofing which I didn't want to do
so I've got the double silent fans up
front pushing air in and then this
pushes air out so I'm hoping that will
be sufficient airflow to give the CPU
cool I've run quite a few tests it seems
to do the trick
now this is the heart and soul of the
gaming portion of it and some video
editing this is a GeForce GTX 780 Ti it
is the newest in the lineup of GeForce
graphic cards by Nvidia I was looking at
the AMD graphics card but I got this one
because this one I think is just as
powerful or slightly more or less
powerful than the Titan which is their
thousand-dollar ultimate super-duper
card but this one is pretty
extraordinary I've never actually bought
or built a computer with components that
were top-of-the-line so this is all new
to me
oh 32 gigs of ram if you were curious
but so it's very new to me to have new
components and I'm pretty proud of what
I've done here because I managed to make
something that is going to last me for
years and years and years now I'm an
amateur when it comes to cable
management so you can see it's kind of a
nest here I don't have anything roped
off or anything like that mostly because
I was still fiddling it with it but you
know it's just it's it's ran where it
needs to be it's ended out where it
needs to be and I've got the components
as a disc drive and my primary SSD 512
gigs 2 4 terabyte storages I'm also
going to get 2 more 2 terabytes to put
in raid 0 for a scratch disk for the
Adobe files that should about cover it
slightly modular power supply yeah
that's about it this is my new baby is
what's going to crank out all the videos
that you're going to see in the future
it's going to do just a fantastic job
and I don't know about you guys but I
take a certain pride in building
something myself and I really enjoy the
idea that what I use is what I build my
dad a long time ago started out in
computers back when they filled up an
entire room and he built computers like
literally built them when it took
individual soldering of capacitors and
resistors onto the board if he wanted to
upgrade it or even make it work you know
everything's modular now so if I would
and building your own just because
cheaper you take pride in it and it's
easy everything only fits in one today
the memory doesn't work you know your
computer won't turn on the instructions
are pretty easy you know there's nothing
really here that'll short itself out
besides like setting up liquid cooling
on the CPU it's generally you know I
don't want to say foolproof but it's
definitely easy so probably got some
friends that know how to do it and love
doing it like I do I love building
computers that probably built quite a
few in my day but anyway that's enough
of that you finally got what you wanted
guys you get to see my new computer
thing this thing is gonna be a bit of a
beast and I can't wait to make videos on
anyway so a sorry gonna put this I'm not
used to used to using the camcorder and
also sorry my hair is a bit of a mess
after thee you know oculus rift debacle
that I had so I hope you guys enjoyed
that and I hope you guys enjoy what's
going to come in the future try to get
myself situated here that's good it's
gonna get em Hey so anyway thank you
guys so much for watching thank you so
much for believing in me thank you so
much for inspired me to push myself to
be a better person you know I'm I'm more
proud of myself than I have been in the
past
or satisfied with where I'm going I'm
more proud of what you guys have done
for the world you know it stopped being
small long time ago and I know it's just
only growing since then it's not gotten
any less meaningful I I'm still excited
every day to get up and entertain you
guys I'm still excited to bust my hump
and I've been out of town every weekend
for the past two months flying on planes
here and they're prepping things but
it's all worth it because you guys make
it worth it so thank you for watching I
hope you're there this Saturday this
Saturday
it's gonna sound terrible but this
Saturday so thank you guys again and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye